not only those stories which appeared in
the new york times and the poll of
democrats saying they don't want biden
to run which the new york times made
that lead story on the front page look
at the timeless coverage of biden's trip
to saudi arabia it was brutal for a joe
biden yeah it's as if a flip has
switched near times where they've made
the cop the judgment that it's time for
a younger different democrat to take
biden down that we don't want by them to
run for reelection you almost get that
sense that they have an editorial change
in terms of the headlines on the front
page now i'll predict to you dave
it's a passing stage
they'll do this until it doesn't work
and then if biden declares for
re-election all of a sudden the new york
times is going to say look at the vigor
he's got as a 82 year old man look at
how strong he is
so a lot of people always ask me was it
always this bad and i try to you know
think back i'm 46. i remember the
nightly news on you know abc cbs nbc and
it was basically whether you liked
brokaw or peter jennings or uh what's
his name dan rather uh but that the the
structure of the show and what they
covered was basically the same uh they
weren't you know it was maybe the order
was a little bit different but they
pretty much were covering the same
things or walter cronkite before that do
you think there was too much um
protection over topics that maybe they
weren't talking about back then well
protection over topics what i would say
is there was
too much of a one-sided nature of
storytelling
how often would you see on the news
about a good guy with a gun stop
stopping a guy with a gun and a killing
because he needed gun control so if a
citizen who had a concealed carry
stopped a crime
they didn't tell you about that because
that would have been the case for
concealed carry the trial of hermit
gosnell which i talk about in my book
probably the greatest serial killer in
american history an abortion doctor who
delivered who
thousands upon thousands of babies he
sniffed the spinal cords a baby's about
to be born late term abortionist
and his trial was suppressed there was
hardly any news coverage of it america's
greatest serial killer why because if
the network went wall-to-wall with
coverage of that trial it actually had
people think twice about being pro-life
or pro-choice and in a newsroom that's
yucky to have people who think pro-life
be legitimized nobody thinks like that
inside a newsroom
so there was a absence of coverage and
again this is what great gave way to fox
news box said you're only telling one
side of a story you're leaving on the
cutting room floor so much of american
life
um
so that's what was wrong with the three
networks back in their heyday you know
when reagan was president some 50 or 60
million americans watched abc nbc cbs at
6 30 eastern in the evening
and now only 20 million do
30 to 35 million went elsewhere they
went to fox and they went to the
diversification of other outlets so when
you were press secretary and there was a
little more honesty there um now when
you watch and it's so out of control and
you mentioned peter ducey we show a lot
of clips of him on the show uh but it's
not just that the pr that the press
themselves are worse it seems like the
press secretaries have gotten much worse
uh let's say the last two specifically
uh that sake i mean the woman simply
i don't think could say a true statement
my line on her was always if you asked
her what her favorite color was she
would say four i mean she just couldn't
say anything true and now you got uh
this corrine jean-pierre who actually
seems worse i mean completely
unqualified am i overstating it with
these two am i not giving enough credit
to how difficult the job is well let me
put it this way and here i am old school
um the job is hard enough and i i will
not
make fun or take on a fellow
a press secretary uh i just i don't i
don't think it's fitting for me to do
that i understand people or make the
criticisms
i won't be one of those people doing it
by name i just will say their problem is
not a communications problem their
problem is a joe biden judgment decision
policy problem old age problem they have
a lot other things that they have to
deal with
other people can take on their
communication skills
okay so putting aside the the specifics
of the two of them generally as far as
the administration right now it seems
like so many things are wrong and you
just mentioned that the media doesn't
cover certain things finally it looks
like in the last two weeks
there are suddenly discussions about
what's going on with biden cognitively
and is he up to the job and it's even
leaking into cnn now a whole bunch of us
were talking about it before the
election but is that another piece of
this that they just airlock certain
things and then we can all see it we all
know something's not right he can't read
off the prompter anymore the rambling
the incoherent nonsense not where am i
who's in charge all of this stuff but
now it's finally leaking which means
that eventually it will fully get
through the airlock yeah and not only
those stories which appeared in the new
york times and the poll of democrats
saying they don't want biden to run
which the new york times made that lead
story on the front page look at the
timeless coverage of biden's trip to
saudi arabia it was brutal for for joe
biden yeah it's as if a flip has
switched near times where they've made
the cop the judgment that it's time for
a younger different democrat to take
biden down that we don't want biden to
run for re-election you almost get that
sentence that they have that editorial
change in terms of the headlines on the
front page now i'll predict to you dave
it's a passing stage
they'll do this until it doesn't work
and then if biden declares for
re-election all of a sudden the new york
times is going to say look at the vigor
he's got as an 82-year-old man look at
how strong he is and especially if the
opponent is donald trump they'll flip
right back to their current mode
but it is something to watch right now
because it is interesting they're given
abide in a tough time recently
i'd say to you also
the press was ridiculously easy on biden
throughout the entire campaign
they had their whole body on the scale
because they wanted trump to be defeated
they suppressed stories that would have
hurt biden his failure to read off the
teleprompter and one of the examples i
have in my book is he did at a campaign
event for the afl-cio
a young woman said to him threw him a
softball and said how do you get more
people to join a union and his answer
this is all on tv on on a biden video
his answer was uh
uh
move it up there
yeah the q and the a preloaded on a
teleprompter and until they put the
teleprompter and made it run he didn't
know the answer to how do you get more
people to join a union
what would a normal press corps have
done they'd have pounded the guy he's
about to become possibly the oldest
president in the united states history
if he wins he can't even answer a
question like that did he have a
teleprompter how did he get the answer
written there if he didn't get the cue
ahead of time do you have the people
providing you with audit friendly
audiences giving you questions ahead of
time
everything
was all the ingredients for a feeding
frenzy would you if you were if you were
part of the administration would you be
trying i mean i know they've tried to
hide him he doesn't really do long-form
interviews he always gets the notes with
who he's allowed to call on and then if
he rambles too long he says that he's in
trouble like none of it makes any sense
or is optically positive or any of that
but if you if you were press secretary
or you were in the administration right
now and you saw what was going on
what would you be what would you be
advising the president to do at this
point
oh they're it's beyond advice
frankly there's little to nothing they
can do anymore because it's about policy
it's about what's happened to the
country it's about inflation the cost of
living cost of gas energy heating your
home air conditioning your home buying
food buying coffee
the southern border crime i mean can you
name more tangible things that are
hurting the country no it's not like
social security is going to go bankrupt
in seven years or the medicare trust
fund is going to go bankrupt in a it's
not these big amorphous things it's the
daily things you feel in life am i going
to get mugged walking home can i afford
the things i need to buy to feed my
family this is what's happening to our
country right now and it's a
particularly hidden lower income and
middle-income people
so it's beyond a speech it's beyond
advice it's events
and the public gets it the country gets
it
the only thing i could suggest for joe
biden if he really wants to change
is he should start going after liberal
prosecutors across the country he should
support the recall of la's district
attorney yep if he started to send a
different note that he actually is in
the 1990s joe biden who wants to protect
people's lives and get tough on crime
that could have a different impact
vitamin might be seen differently if he
did that there's very little else you
can do well actually to that point i
mean does this guy bite and strike you
as someone very different than you knew
of say 20 years ago i mean it's almost
like he's sort of the perfect candidate
for the left because he doesn't know
what he believes anymore he reads
anything and he's just ushering in the
destruction that i personally i think
that the more radical people want i
don't think he wants to destroy the
country i just don't think he knows what
he's doing at this point look i've known
joe biden for many decades i used to
work for a different senator from pete
domenici of new mexico i got to know joe
biden and then i knew him when i was at
the white house and i always knew that
joe biden was a blowhard
he was just a talker and he didn't have
much depth he didn't have much substance
as robert gates the former secretary of
defense to george bush and barack obama
said about every foreign policy decision
over the last 30 years joe biden has
gotten wrong
and now that's spread to domestic
decisions too
i mean one of the biggest reasons we
have inflation is because biden insists
on that massive blowout government
spending redistribution package when he
first got elected that he was able to
jam through on a party-line vote
and he doesn't think that contributed to
inflation
biden just has terrible judgment now he
just wants to spend more money and he
really has not shown the spine to stand
up to the woke left he's really become
bernie sanders running mate as opposed
to the nation's leader if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell